hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zum letztlich simulator ich
habe im internet diesen let's play
simulierte to the sixteen gefunden des
goal is to grow up to one million
subscribers wird yahoo youtube channel
hat tube scheint hier wohl irgendwie so
die nachmache von youtube
dementsprechend zu sein bei gamesload
rennen bay street emails carefully preis
ok for more details in remember 40 ist
auch so toll englisch neues place for
you okay dass alle verstanden also wir
müssen die viel wird denn hier erklärt
ich klicke einfach mal auf ok und das
bin ich hier ihr seht wahrscheinlich
gerade nicht dass hier um wie soft
lingen steht und day one deswegen mache
ich mal kurz jetzt meine fans comeback
damit ihr sehen könnt day one piece of
me nachricht geschickt hier sehen wir
wie viel geld wir haben hier oben sehen
wie philips treibers wir haben dass es
genau so sieht mein tisch auch aus hat
jack roulette player rolle teamleiter
game call jazzfans bei unicef vielleicht
heißt dass ubisoft das live ist das dir
sogar so social media
jetzt hat er das hier wirklich gerade
bei mir bald wieder geöffnet ich klicke
einfach mal auf jetzt 95 und ihr let's
play vegas/new action game call tonic
wie gate okay es ist wahrscheinlich
nicht sonic the hedgehog aber ich klicke
einfach mal jetzt werde das ganze hier
auf meinem kanal zocken mich ein
bisschen darüber aufregen und ich habe
dadurch 250 neue subscribers das ist
mehr als das was ich bisher okay ich
hatte ja auch nicht so viel heroin
freddie for games in dezimierter games
sieht vorgeht
anstatt need for speed haben sie sieht
vor kit und anstatt ihr games am sie
ihre games ich mache einfach mal
irgendwie sie das spiel war gleich noch
du meine reaktionen sind ein bisschen
anders und 299 neueste treiber kann ich
noch mehr machen in diesem spiel wo die
let's play offs teenie horror game call
bubblegum esales ag ja ja klar mache ich
das natürlich bekommen
ich bin im plus freunde kann ich denn
hier irgendwie mal auch was anderes
anklicken als irgend kann ich nicht ich
kann echt nichts anders machen ja
natürlich will ich das auch noch spielen
das ist ja ein super tolles spiel hat
mich gerade meinen eigenen kanal wie
klickt man einfach auf know how to
replace neues leben change und beim
nächsten das ist das ist nein das möchte
ich auch nicht machen das ist und dass
das ist josef like your photos for you
like von instagram wahrscheinlich in
savannah rahmenordnung das ist das was
da so komisch aufgebot kommt teilweise
ließ review des great barrier schottky
miguel ja natürlich flüge das spiel das
ist dass das wird wahrscheinlich auch
super beim einen abonnenten das ist -
neuen super meine miete ist 6 dollar
krank joghurt trend is your friend
exzellent ich schaue da bin ihr stream
ok speaker john cusack agent 43 63 was
nur bei meiner freundin kommen rein
vielleicht mache ich dann auch ein paar
mehr hinten ein spaß da da da ist da ist
niemand
bin ganz allein die hatten eine episode
über mich und das ist auch wieder ein
big alliance boots oder 36 aller das ist
ja hammer ich muss leider eine million
erreichen und ich 707 80 have you sing
your mobile games kolko marie lüfter
denn da komm ich mach das mal vielleicht
mache ich dadurch ja wieder ein paar -
selbst und kann meinen channel mit ihr
weiter den ruin
aber natürlich - neuen leven beauty
videos als oberin york review of scrap
typischer kommentar unter meinem video
you can let's play off a 1040 news
simulator game fifa.com gutachten spiel
ist einfach nur bezug auf das man dass
man - 177 mein channel wurde die idee
dort ja das fein page game natürlich
werde ich das region das ist ja eines
meiner lieblingsspiele das ist schon mal
mein ich
habe so viele neue subscribers habe ich
mir gedacht ich mache einfach mal direkt
hier das nächste video wer kann er
seiner tief darüber freuen dass ich
jetzt hier direkt wieder ganz schön
viele verloren oder ein ballerspiel das
sollte mir auf jeden fall in einen oder
anderen älteren oder halb gleich 722
neueste treiber dieses dass das ist
tatsächlich alles laut schrie die
software uk let's play off take it
security fps game ok first person
shooter dich sogar das ist bestimmt auf
meinem kaya 718 ist ja toll wie die
tische bleibe und playa türlich würde
ich mich freuen darüber ein video zu
machen das geht wahrscheinlich wieder
700 subscriber wieder 743 63
ja natürlich spiele ich dieses tolle
spiel was ihr hier
781 6 freunde diese sendet dem wir so
einen scheiß zu es ist das blöd deswegen
soll ich das mit dem klatschen mal
lassen sich damit einmal angefangen und
seitdem mache ich sie mal was fakt mich
überhaupt wenn euch das video gefallen
hat dann als ob es euch gefallen hat
zeigt für mit einer bewertung übrigens
das was ihr hier im hintergrund seht das
ist mein merchandise falls sie das noch
nicht wusstet weil ich so selten erwähne
ich glaube dass es wieder verfügbar ist
auf der website in einigen größen ich
bin mir aber nicht sicher also einfach
mal auf luca - shop.de gehen könnte da
schon ob man sie bestellen kann oder
nicht
schauen wir dass eine video heißt puke
nukem
anstatt duke nukem bleibt das video und
schreibt mir andere spieler die
vielleicht gut sind in die kommentare
danke